is it true that the birth control pill
can change your perception of who you're
attracted to for a woman yeah that is
concerning what they found was that when
women who chose their Partners on the
pill discontinue the pill it is
associated with changes in how attracted
they are to their partner their sexual
satisfaction and their relationship
satisfaction and what was really
fascinating about it is that whether
that got better or whether it got worse
depended on how attractive their partner
was lovely okay what about rates of
depression and other side effects and
Are there specific people who are more
prone to this Research indicates that
girls who go on it during their
teenagers that this is something that
can put them at risk for having major
depressive disorder across their
lifetime even after they go off of it o
nobody's really paying attention to this
which is kind of BS yeah I've read some
stories of women accidentally getting
testosterone when they didn't need it
and experiencing wild heightened sexual
arousal do you know anything about that
is that true this should be a good
one welcome to my podcast thanks I'm
excited to be here yeah this should be a
good one um I've been interested in
having this conversation for a while
because I was on birth control from age
14 to
23 um originally for skin problems so I
just like went to the doctor and they're
like you know you're skin is not great
here's a birth control pill and I was
like sweet No period that sounds
fantastic um and then I think you talk
to my mom right you on her podcast I did
I did yes it was great she told me as
soon as I started taking it she said oh
that pill made me really depressed and
my response was I'm already really
depressed so I don't care that was like
the 14-year-old naive response so I
think this this should be a good
conversation I've got a bunch of
questions for you but um I thought yeah
I thought we should start off with just
is it true that the birth control pill
can change your perception of who you're
attracted to for a
woman yeah you know it that is a
possibility and this is something that
um sort of is rooted in research that's
been done for about three decades now um
researchers have been finding that uh
women's cycling their cyclically
changing sex hormones uh play a role in
who they're attracted to and in
particular what this research finds is
that when estrogen is high across the
cycle that this is associated with an
increased preference for cues related to
testosterone markers and like
masculinity and um so for example at
high fertility across the cycle when
estrogen is high we find that women like
deeper male voices they like more
masculinized male faces they're more
likely to be attracted to cues of social
dominance and so it's like women really
sort of like like zero in on on
masculinity markers um when fertility is
high and when estrogen is high across
the cycle and it was only more recently
that researchers thought to ask you know
what happens when we suppress women's
estrogen levels with the birth control
pill um because when you take the birth
control pill it um prevents you from
ovulating and it's that process of
maturing egg follicles and getting an
egg ready to be released that causes the
release of of estrogen that's one of the
primary ways that our body produces
estrogen and um the Pill by preventing
ovulation keeps estrogen levels really
low and then the the pill that you take
has very low levels of synthetic
estrogen in it and so researchers
thought to ask you know do women who are
on hormonal birth control because their
estrogen levels are low does this lead
them to prefer less masculinized male
faces and voices and so on and so forth
and what they find is that that does
appear to be true and that women who are
on hormonal birth control have a
preference for a less masculinized male
face um they've done studies where they
look at photographs of men who were
chosen as partners by women who are on
hormonal birth control or off of it and
they put the pictures of the men into
two stacks and then they had them
evaluated for masculinity as rated by
you know just a outside group of people
who didn't know which men were in which
condition and then they also looked at
more objective metrics of masculinity
you can um look at facial masculinity by
looking at things like facial width to
height which are correlated with
testosterone levels and what they find
is that the part the men who were chosen
by women as partners that were on
hormonal birth control is that they had
less masculine faces relative to um the
The Men Who were chosen by naturally
cycling women um which is really
mind-blowing when you think about it h
yeah do you think that so do you know
what percentage of women say that are of
like childbearing age are on hormonal
birth
control yeah you know I don't know um in
some so like with college samples for
example it's almost like 40% of women
are on hormonal birth control because
they're you know trying to get stay
unpregnant while they're getting their
degrees and that sort of thing um but in
terms of like the overall population I'm
I'm not sure but it's a sizable number I
mean this is the number one demographic
of women who are on it are women in
their 20s and this is usually when women
are choosing Partners um and so that's
you know potentially something that
could be really consequential for
women guys I wanted to talk to you
briefly about air purifiers and air
quality I've had various air purifiers
for years and I knew air quality was
important but I've learned a lot too
much this year after getting sick from
mold and I've settled on aasis as my
go-to air purifier I actually reached
out to them to see if they'd sponsor me
because they are the best air purifier I
could find and now I know how important
they are there are few reasons why I
chose
aoas these filter down to 0.03 microns
which is actually important it means
they actually filter partial allergens
and mold spores and there was only
recently that I realized most air
purifiers filter down to 0.01 microns
which means they miss fragments which
make up the majority of allergens in the
air these also work on voc's like new
paint gases viruses Etc I used to say if
you guys have allergies get one of these
and definitely do but everyone should
actually have one or multiple of these
in their house given the amount of
chemicals molds and air pollutants were
exposed to a Oasis is quiet which is
important because a lot of them aren't
quiet quiet sleek and filters down to
the right particle size compared to the
majority of other air purifiers so check
them out don't just get any air purifier
investing in one of these is so worth it
for your health they're at aasis
docomo the rest of this episode do you
think that the correlation between you
said 40% of college students on the pill
do you think when they get into
relationships there's a higher
likelihood of divorce
you know that's a really interesting
question and there's kind of two lines
of research that point in different
directions uh the one line of research
is some longitudinal research that's
been done of newlywed married couples
and they followed them over time to look
at changes in things like sexual
satisfaction and relationship
satisfaction over the course of uh the
marriage and one of the research
questions that that that they thought to
ask was for women who choose their
Partners when they're on hormonal birth
control um does their relationship and
sexual satisfaction for example change
um if they discontinue and so these
researchers followed these women over
time and what they found was that when
women who chose their Partners on the
pill discontinue the pill it is
associated with changes in like how um
attracted they are to their partner um
and uh their sexual satisfaction and
their relationship satisfaction and what
was fascinating about it is that whether
that got better or whether it got worse
depended on how attractive their partner
was so for women so for women who were
partnered to attractive men when they
went off the pill it was like the
blinders came off you know and all of a
sudden they're having these estrogen
changes again and they're like oh yes
right and they're more attracted to
their partner and they um and they're
more sexually satisfied and and then as
a result of that they're also more
satisfied in their relationship but they
found that for women who were partnered
to less attractive partners that the
opposite happened and that the women
became less sexually satisfied less
attracted their partner and then their
relationship satisfaction decreased and
so it could potentially you know when
we're choosing our partners on the pill
it could potentially nudge us into the
direction of choosing somebody that
we're not attracted to but that doesn't
always happen and so you know it's like
whether it makes it more positive or
more negative when you go off of it a
lot of times depends on the partner that
you
show okay okay that makes sense so it's
not just like Doom and Gloom for people
who are on birth control and like oh no
now I'm married and going to go off of
it going to see my partner entirely
different light yeah no totally I mean
because when we look at the way that
hormones affect like women's Brains and
they affect women's Behavior it's not
like it's like going to move you from
here to over here instead it just kind
of nudges it nudges our behavior in
different ways or it might udge you
toward a you know more masculinized
partner it might udge you toward you
know somebody who's got this quality or
that quality but it's um and for some
women it will you know there is the
unfortunate circumstance where it can
nudge people in a direction that that
when they're off of it they don't feel
attracted to their partner again but for
a lot of women it's subtle and for other
women it can actually make um them feel
better and like more attracted to their
partner once they're off of it and so
yeah not Doom and Gloom it just all
depends so so that's already a weird I
guess you could call it side effect that
people weren't expecting from from birth
control right what about rates of
depression and other side effects and
Are there specific people who are more
prone to this is it
random right no these are really great
questions um there's definitely you know
there's a lot of research that's
pointing in the direction that being on
hormonal birth control can increase your
risk of anxiety and depression um and
this risk seems to be particularly high
for young women so um women who are like
19 and younger um seem to be the ones
who overwhelmingly shoulder the burden
of the greater mental health risks um
and researchers really don't know
exactly why that is but I would assume
that it has something to do with the
fact that the brain is still developing
and that our ability to regulate our
emotions is still developing at that
time and that changing that and changing
our hormones um isn't something that our
our mood and our our sort of emotion
regulation system is able to handle very
well there's also a research that
indicates that girls who go on it um go
on hormonal birth control during
adolescence so during their teenagers
that this is something that can put them
at risk for having major depressive
disorder across their lifetime even
after they go off of it and this is
something I know and this is something
that's really concerning to me and it's
very concerning to a lot of researchers
because nobody's really paying attention
to this um and there's so many doctors
out there who do exactly what yours did
and they prescribe hormonal birth
control to teenage girls for things like
acne or having irregular Cycles or
having bad cramps without understanding
that when you take hormones and you shut
down your brain ovary you know ovarian
axis during development that this could
potentially have long-term consequences
in terms of brain development because
our brain is still developing and our
sex hormones play an important role in
the pubertal transition that goes on and
and that post Lial brain development and
very much influenced in important ways
by our sex hormones and so that's
something that um you know hasn't been
very well studied there aren't nearly
enough studies that have investigated
The Links of a Teenage pill use a
long-term outcomes but the work that has
been done like I said is not painting a
very positive picture and it seems like
there's a potential risk there um and in
terms of like who is affected you know
and one of the risks factors as
mentioned is you know being a teenager
and so we know that teenagers are at a
greater risk of this than um than other
women but there seem to be even in adult
women like there is an increased risk so
many studies find that um there's a
increased risk particularly with um the
progestin only pill so that's the one
that's now available over the counter um
that one is like is always I mean almost
almost every time they study it they
find that being on that type of uh birth
control is um predicts a greater risk of
developing anxiety and depression um
another yeah which is concerning to me
like I I think it's great that we're
allowing greater access to birth control
particularly in this sort of post row
dystopian world that we're living in at
the moment um which I don't think is
very good for Women's Health but um but
it's really concerning that women will
take this without anybody know you know
knowing that they're on it which could
potentially be really devastating um if
you're a girl who just starts taking
this birth control and developing a mood
disorder and you don't know what's wrong
with you because most of the time when
we develop a mood disorder from a drug
it's not like we think oh you know gosh
my drug is making me feel bad we just
think oh I'm depressed um you know we
don't think about it that way and so I I
I do worry about that um that one any
nonoral product is associated with a
greater risk of depression like they
tend to find that pretty regularly so
the hormonal IUD the vaginal ring the
implant the shot um those are the ones
that tend to have the greatest risk um
the combined pill um is also found to be
associated with an increased risk of
anxiety and depression but the rate of
that is lower than it is for these wow
yeah for the the like um the non-oral
products or for the progestin Hill um
and so different products have different
risk profiles and then lastly there's
also individual differences that we just
don't understand and unfortunately you
know the research isn't in a isn't in a
position right now like where we can
tell women like you Michaela are at an
increased risk of developing depression
from this um and so we need a lot more
research into um the different types of
factors that influence women's risk
factors because some women have a great
experience on hormonal birth control
they feel great and they don't have any
problems at all and other women have you
know a list of side effects 10 miles
long and we're not yet medicine isn't in
a POS in a place yet where we can make
good recommendations for who's going to
respond what way to what thing yeah yeah
that's very complicated I know um like I
I suppose if you were looking into this
you would assume that people who are
already kind of on the anxious side
might respond more
but um I have this friend one of my best
friends in Toronto who's a very bubbly
person and wasn't prone to anxiety like
I was as a teenager uh and she went on
the pill and after a couple weeks she
was crying every day which concerned me
because I figured people who are already
kind of prone to anxiety are the ones
that are going to get depressed on birth
control but then this bubbly person
turned into like a crying mess after a
couple weeks um right but to comment on
one thing you said first of all I didn't
realize there was any type of birth
control that was available over the
counter now is that just an that like
and is it marketed as lower hormone
because it's only one of the
hormones I don't know if it's marketed
as lower hormone I know that the reason
that they uh allowed that one to be
available over the counter is because um
the greater risk of you know like uh
heart attack and stroke and that sort of
thing from birth control comes from the
estrogen in it um and so they they made
this one available because it's uh the
synthetic progesterone or progestin only
and so because of that way it's safer in
terms of your heart and you know your
blood vessels and your cardiovascular
system but it's less safe in terms of
mental health because it is um the one
that's got the worst side effect profile
by a mile that and anything that's
progestin only like that Pro like the
birth control shot is also prestant only
and that's also got a side effect w
sheet that's worse than many of the
other types of birth control out there
so how did these how did these get like
shuttled through and made available to
everybody like didn't they do testing
and see any of these side effects so
that at least when you got a
prescription a doctor could be like hey
you know it might work for you but if
you're experiencing weeping every day
and these like strong emotions maybe
don't stay on it for 10 years and
attribute it to something else like it
could be the pill right yeah no I think
that the reason that they made it
available is because they wanted to have
something that was available that was
reliable and easy to use um because of
what happened with the do's decision and
overturning the you know row and I think
that it was like when they made um you
know they they removed the guarantee of
um legality of abortions for women they
figured well we have to do something to
try to prevent women from getting into
this position and so I think that that
was the decision that everybody sort of
landed on is that this would be
something that would be positive for
women's reproductive Health which in
some ways it is I mean preventing
unwanted pregnancies is like one of the
best things that we can do societally um
for women just because um like the
biggest predictor of ending up in
poverty as a woman is is a teenage
pregnancy and um and so like there's
benefits that way but as you noted I
mean the the thing that makes me nuts
and of course you know I'm a
psychologist so I'm going to say this
but people don't take mental health
risks as seriously as they do physical
health risks so for example you know
like the the risk of a heart attack and
stroke for example is seen as a safety
issue right and so they're like oh well
this you know um the the pill that has
estrogen in it has a safety risk and so
you know BL but like a mental health
risk isn't seen as a safety risk it's
just seen as sort of a nuisance side
effect which is kind of BS I mean
it's like you think about how important
your mental health is and you also
consider like what the suicide rate is
right now um and I mean you know
depression like severe depression can be
deadly um it can because it causes
people to take their own lives and it
and it ruins the quality of lives and um
and I don't know if this is what you
were alluding to but I mean I know
myself I was on the birth control pill
for over 10 years myself and I used to
have this narrative about myself or I
believed that I was anxious and and a
little Melancholy and depressed and
that's not me at all but I believed that
to be true of myself because I was on it
for all these years and I had these
spells of anxiety and depression and
then when I went off of it I realized
that that wasn't me and then I didn't
even really know who I was and that that
was this totally different experience
for
me yeah I think I think people
completely underestimate this I had a
similar experience it was a little bit
more complicated cuz I was also on an
anti-depressant and I started the
anti-depressant before I started the
birth control so I already had the
narrative that I was miserably depressed
which is why I told my mom I don't care
like well add a little depression on
this mess of depression is not going to
make a difference anyway um but I don't
like I I know also from having arthritis
throughout my life I know that the
Depression was worse than the arthritis
like I would have ch chosen the
arthritis because you can deal with some
pain like when you get a cold you can
deal with not feeling good physically
but when it hits your brain that is a
completely other like that's a
completely different story it's it's
life altering changes your perception of
who you are like you said your
perception of other people your
perception of what you're capable of
like it can just destroy your life and
then you said you were on it for 10
years which is like that's an entire
decade of your life
yeah I know terrible yeah no it is
terrible and it it really concerns me
that you know when you have this
available and like I said I feel very
ambivalent about it because on the one
hand I think that we need to do
everything that we can Society to help
make sure that uh women who are trying
to avoid pregnancy are able to do so um
just because of you know what we know
about the risks of um ending up in
poverty and not being able to continue
educational goals and so on and so forth
forth for women who end up unexpectedly
pregnant but at the same time um having
this pill available over the counter
when nobody's being supervised and have
other people watching them to say Hey
you know you haven't really been
yourself the last couple of weeks um
what's going on um is is worrying
because then these girls um can end up
in a situation where they're miserably
depressed nobody knows what's wrong with
them and there's a really easy solution
to it you know to fix that um and and
and it has to do with their birth
control yikes so for people if you said
40% of approximately 40% of college AED
women are on women in college women in
college righten in college women or E
College yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so if
people are friends with someone or if
they're in a relationship with someone
who's experiencing heightened anxiety
and they're on the pill are there
resources that they can say hey maybe
you should check out I mean obviously
you and you have a book right that maybe
people could go read and say just so you
know this could be happening to you
right no absolutely and in my book um
which is this is your brain on birth
control one of the things that I talk
about is the different types of hormonal
birth control because there's like four
different generations of what are known
as progestins which is that synthetic
progesterone that's in the pill and
there's like four different categories
of those and so for example if a woman
is experiencing depr de and she's on
hormonal birth control she can like look
and see what's in hers and I've got a
list on there of like popular birth
controls that are out there and which
you know which one tends to fall into
what category and the best thing that
women can do is just even start
troubleshooting by going to their doctor
and saying hey you know I'm on this pill
I feel my mental health is in the toilet
um I'm on something that has a second
generation progestin in it let's try a
fourth generation progestin pill and
then trying something different because
these the synthetic progesterone that's
in hormonal birth control is um is is
different depending on what sort of
category it falls into and they do very
different things in the body um so just
to give you an example a second
generation
progestin is actually synthesized from
testosterone and because of that in
addition to um stimulating progesterone
receptors it also stimulates
testosterone receptors and it also
stimulates glucocorticoid receptors yeah
so it it has this really messy it can
have really messy nonspecific effects in
the brain and in the body um but then
like a fourth generation progestin for
example is synthesized from um uh
diuretic called
spalone and it also it stimulates I mean
it's just like everything is messy all
these progestins are messy and they all
do something a little bit different
because they affect different receptors
in the brain and and to the rest of the
body and so if you don't like a
prescription of a birth control that
you're on um but you really are
motivated to be on hormonal birth
control um I give really um I give
recommendations like actionable
recommendations for what women can do to
then you know try to find something
different that they like better and that
their body responds differently
too so is it dependent on the person or
do you think that there are classes of
birth control that have the least amount
of side effects yeah they all have side
effects um and all of them are sort of
like different you know what I so it's
like for example with the second
generation uh progestins for example
like you tend to get um some side
effects that are related to
masculinization because of the
testosterone receptors and so you'll get
like skin breakouts and some women will
like grow start growing facial hair and
you get water retention um but then the
fourth generation progestins are
actually anti-androgenic and so your
skin clears up and you look really good
but then because it's Block it's
blocking testosterone you a lot of times
you can get um decreases in libido and
so it's like with each one of these you
end up it's like pick your poison you
know and so it's really about
understanding um what the the different
side effects are of these different
types of progestins and then sort of
picking the one that works the best for
your body and then for your individual
goals because for some women having
clear skin is going to be more important
than it is for others for example and so
women if you know that then you can go
and you can sort of start to do a semic
customization of your birth control
based on your goals but to get at one of
the other points you raised and that's
that you know the way that each person
metabolizes all of those different
synthetic hormones is also going to
differ and so for example you and I
could be on the exact same formula of
hormonal birth control and have vastly
different respon responses like it could
make it could like ruin your sex drive
and make your skin look amazing and like
for me it could make my skin look
terrible but not affect my sex drive
it's like um and we're not unfortunately
at a place yet with research where we
can make good predictions about who's
going to respond what way to what thing
and so a lot of it for women ends up
being a crapshoot um and I do like to
think that um the information I provide
in my book provides a starting point for
allowing women to be able to at least
have some footing in terms of where to
get started in terms of what pill might
work best for their body I hope you guys
had a fantastic Halloween I dressed up
like a cow if you woke up feeling like
garbage after because you drank and you
don't normally drink or maybe you do
normally drink but you still felt bad
and you haven't tried my Afterparty pill
try it I don't need to interrupt you for
very long it works to significantly
reduce your hangover and help you break
down a cahide studies are available on
the website I wouldn't be Shilling this
out if it didn't actually work because
that is a great way to destroy your
brand and I wouldn't want to do that
30-day money well not just that I also
don't like lying so these work 30-day
money back guarantee code MP for 15% off
that code won't be around forever
available Fuller health.com we'll be
rolling out more supplements in the
future with no fillers just pure
ingredients like this one this is pure
dihydro my ristin
these actually work they work how you
want them to work unlike birth control
enjoy the rest of this
episode so do you have kids or no kids I
do I've got
two okay uh do you have any daughters I
do my oldest is a daughter so I have a
16-year-old
daughter okay so what like what was your
if you don't mind what was your
discussion with her because I know what
my discussion would be but I'm so far I
got so hurt from psych medications
really I don't even know what birth
control was doing because the psych
medication side effects were so bad but
my like
my response now which is probably I've
gone so far in the other direction of
just avoid everything they all have side
effects who knows what they're doing to
you and they're like sneaky side effects
you won't figure out just don't take
anything like that's my response but
then it does come with the risk of
unwanted pregnancy like it does um what
like what do you tell people to do
that's a really that's like well no I
mean this this is the $8 million
question right I mean this is the thing
that I talk with my friends about and
other researchers about um and in fact
the last chapter of my book is called um
what now a letter to my daughter and
like yeah and it sort of discusses like
what what to think about when you're
thinking about whether to go on hormonal
birth control or not and that if you're
going to be on it like what type to to
choose and like what are some of the
considerations that you want to make
when you're making that decision just
because whether it's going to be right
or not right for each individual woman
is going to depend on her unique life
circumstances and her goals and her
values and so I don't like to make any
sort of indication about what anybody
should do instead I just like raised
like what are some of the things you
should think about when you are making a
decision about going on birth control
and like one of them is like yeah do do
I need to be on it am I in a sexual
relationship or not um am you know like
what are my career goals like how how
terrible would it be if I had an
unprotected pregnancy right now cuz like
for a married woman who's considering
having kids soon anyway that might not
be catastrophic but for an 18-year-old
it probably would be and so you know it
just sort of delineates what some of
those questions are but um I mean it's
really hard like the thing that I think
is terrible for women is that we are in
this position where you know fertility
regulation is the most important thing
for us in terms of our ability to ensure
um that we can meet our educational
goals and our career goals and um and we
just don't have a lot of good options um
for birth control I mean there's barrier
methods like condoms and that sort of
thing which you know work they're not
perfect um but of course they're
inconvenient and a lot of times people
don't like them um then you've got you
and you've also got the um the uh uh
diaphragm which is another barrier
method which is a little cup that goes
in um you put it up in your vagina and
you snap it over the end of your cervix
and um and that prevents it serves as a
barrier between you know uh the vaginal
canal and then the cervix um which can
prevent pregnancy and use spermicide
with that um and that also but again
that's not perfect I think that the I
don't know what the failure rate is but
it's it's high than it is for hormonal
birth control and then there's the IUD
you know and the copper
IUD doesn't have hormones um and so
that's like positive um but uh it does
create a little bit of an inflammatory
response in the servics and uterus area
and for women who are really sensitive
to inflammation and some women are
really sensitive to it others are less
so um it can also cause um uh
psychological side effects it's very
rare but it does happen um just because
some women are really sensitive to um
fluctuating levels of uh inflammatory
markers even at very low levels um and
then you've got you know like uh the
fertility awareness method which is
where you track your cycle and then you
have unprotected sex during the time in
the cycle when conception is not
possible which for the last two weeks of
your cycle during the ludal phase after
you've um ovulated uh more than 24 hours
ago you can have sex safely without
worrying about pregnancy for about two
weeks um a little bit more than that so
some women will do that but that one's
got a little bit of a high failure rate
as well just because you know not
everybody's going to be able to
perfectly track their cycle and I
certainly wouldn't recommend that to my
16-year-old daughter you know I was like
she can hardly keep track of where her
lunchbox is I'm not going to have her
like tracking her cycle to keep track of
um fertility and so you know for her and
and for you know me having conversations
with her um is like when she's ready to
like if she needs uh contraception I
think that the first thing that we're
going to try is the non- hormonal IUD
just because it's so um it's so good at
pre preventing pregnancy and that's
something that especially at a young age
for women is so super important and it's
not going to be changing her hormone
levels which to for me as somebody knows
about brain development and then the
potential you know elevated risk of
developing anxiety and depression over
the course of the lifetime it's I'm
really motivated to keep her off of
synthetic hormones until she's at least
20 and then at that point we can start
considering whether or not a combination
hormonal birth control pill because if I
was going to recommend a hormonal
product to an adult woman whose brain is
done developing I would say try one of
the combination birth control pills
because those do seem to be the ones
with the least amount of side effects H
okay that's all good that seems wise
yeah it It's Tricky being female is
tricky it really is tricky I mean I
think that one of the things that's
really frustrating to me is that you
know women have been talking about
having side effects from birth control
forever I mean this isn't a new
conversation um and yet there's no
innovation being made in this space I
mean there's just not investment by the
drug companies um back into coming up
with new ways for women to um prevent
pregnancy um instead you know the only
R&D that's really being done is they're
looking to create a birth control pill
for men which is a step in the right
direction in terms of Fairly shouldering
the burden of contraception within a
couple but at the same time it's just
shifting the problem from women onto men
and that's not the right answer either
so it's like okay
the what they have out there right now
is something that keeps men's
testosterone levels so low that they
don't produce sperm and it's like that's
not what we need you know as a society
to be like making all of our men have
really low levels of testosterone
because testosterone affects a lot more
than sperm production it affects
motivational States you know and all
sorts of other things your desire and
ability to compete I mean it affects a
lot of different stuff and so like do we
really want to be doing that I mean it's
like I like the idea of having that
available as an option so that way it's
not just women who have to make tough
choices but at the same time that's not
what we need what we need is something
that's totally different because like
you it's like I feel very much you know
my background is in evolutionary biology
I understand our body as being this like
really brilliant machine where we we've
inherited all of these traits that have
helped our ancestors survive and
reproduce and you know our body is
so nicely regulated on its own and then
to like do things like alter our
hormones as a way to um to protect
ourselves from pregnancy is just not the
best idea you know like staying away
from all of that stuff I think is um if
you're able to do it is is is good for
the body it'd be nice in theory if there
was a pill you could just take and like
oh your skin clears up you feel fine
nothing changes and you can avoid
unwanted pregnancies until you're ready
to have a kid that sounds great and
that's how it's sold right that's
basically how it's sold yeah ridiculous
so then is this a like
progestin issue mainly like what happens
when women go through menopause and then
I know a lot of women supplement
hormones after
menopause are they screwed then too no
so here's the thing and it's it really
is a progestin thing so that synthetic
Pro
that's in hormonal birth control does
all kinds of ridiculous crazy things in
the body um just because the B The
Binding is non-specific as I mentioned
like you'll have they'll stimulate
testosterone receptors and they'll
stimulate glucocorticoid receptors and
they'll do all sorts of things that
they're not really you know supposed to
do and all of those things together
create this experience of really weird
side effects and the other thing that
happens is just keeping women's own
endogenous levels of sex hormones really
low because essentially what you're
doing when you're taking the pill is
you're shutting down the brain over axis
and you're not producing any hormones
and that's a really unusual State for
the female body to be in we are very
much hormonal creatures and you know the
the experience that women have when
they're going through uh menopause is
what happens like women often times feel
terrible because their hormone levels
are really low
and that doesn't feel normal for them
and so their bodies feel bad and you
know they get mood swings and they get
vaginal dryness and some other things
that are the result of having low levels
of uh sex hormone and when women do a
menopausal hormone therapy which is
where they're taking synthetic hormones
um to try to increase their hormone
levels to ease that transition that
oftentimes makes women feel a lot better
than they do in the absence of it and uh
these these hormones are are pretty much
biolog ically identical and so when
you're doing menopausal horm theapy
you're taking a synthetic estrogen which
um is very similar to what you have in
the pill the synthetic estrogen really
isn't the problem it's those synthetic
progestins that are so goofy and when
you're doing menopausal hormone therapy
you um you actually take uh a
bioidentical um progesterone so you
actually take micronized progesterone
instead of taking a progestin and so um
that actually and up being a lot better
for women and just to give you an
example of of why that's true it like in
addition to the fact that uh you know
synthetic progestins will bind to
hormone receptors that have nothing to
do with progesterone and can make you
feel kind of crazy um progesterone like
the real deal progesterone that our body
creates and then also is in micronized
progesterone that women use in uh
hormone therapy um when that gets
metabolized by the body it actually
releases a neurosteroid called Alo
pregnanolone that is like really
positive for mental health and so it's
something that's very calming it um it
uh helps to facilitate gabaergic
activity in the brain which slows the
brain down and makes it feel calm and
relaxed and um so taking Progesterone
you get all of these nice um
neurological benefits that are calming
and relaxing but with the synthetic
progestin
because they aren't even synthesized
from progesterone you don't get that
because when the body is metabolizing
the synthetic progestin there's no
neurosteroid there there's no Alo
pregnanolone there's nothing calming and
relaxing instead you're just
metabolizing a wonky version of
testosterone for example and the ones
that are made out of um testosterone and
so you don't get wow yeah no it's a
totally different ball game than regular
progesterone and um sometimes I think
progesterone are natural hormone and the
one that women take in menopausal
hormone therapy um gets a bad wrap as
being this like you know negative bad
mood hormone um just because people are
confusing it with the synthetic
progesterone that's in the pill that
makes people feel
terrible okay I didn't know any of that
I was like all the research I did on
birth control and then I got you know
like I said spooked out from spooked out
to say the least from from other
medications
um I was worried about yeah what to do
after menopause I mean do you go oh
natural what if you're really suffering
can you take any of those is it the same
thing as taking uh birth control I had
no idea that that was actually a
different form of progesterone because I
know when you get pregnant right your
progesterone skyrockets and isn't that
supposed to make you kind of feel calm
during pregnancy so then how could it be
the opposite with birth control why
don't they just use the same couldn't
they just use the same progesterone as
they used to treat like
postmenopausal symptoms right that you
know I love that question because I had
the exact same question like I went to
um because I'm not an MD so I'm not a
doctor you know I'm a research
psychologist so I study everything from
the neck up and I was like why in the
world are birth control pills made from
this synthetic trash you know instead of
like just using this other thing that's
good and here was the and here's the I
was given um so the first part of the
answer is it took a really long time um
for researchers uh to be able to figure
out how to make a Sol like a a version
of progesterone that you can take as a
tablet or like as a as a pill that would
pass the re or that would pass the
digestive tract and be able to be
absorbed in the body and so it took um
it took them a long time to be able to
do that and uh so it wasn't available
micronize progesterone had wasn't really
available until I don't know how many
years now but it it was after birth
control pills had sort of come on the
scene right but then now that it is
available and that we use it for things
like menopausal hormone therapy and that
sort of thing um why isn't why aren't we
using it in in birth control and the
answer I was given was that you would
have to take it in such high doses to
ensure that you're not um going to uh
allow your brain to start stimulating
your ovaries because you have to have
high levels of progesterone
for your brain to not tell your ovaries
to produce an egg which is how um the
birth control pill works is that you'd
have to take it in such high doses that
it would make women just like way too
tired and because it makes you like when
you take synthetic or when you take um
bioidentical progesterone it makes you
sleepy and some other things and that
you'd have to take it in such high doses
that it might have an like intolerable
side effects but that being said I've
never seen it being tried you know I've
never seen that I've never heard of
anybody trying to do that and um and I
and I think that it's a fascinating
alternative to at least try that to see
whether that's something that's possible
um and and and I don't know the answer
to that like I said I'm not an MD um but
the MDS I talked to when I asked them
about that that that was their answer
was that you know you you the dosage
that you have to take is is really high
to ensure that you're preventing
pregnancy and that it would just not be
something that was very well tolerated
by most
women but we haven't tried it and the
severe side effect of depression and
choosing a slightly different mate is
definitely better than being too relax
fued I know yeah I know yeah no I don't
understand like like I said that's
always been my question and I was
thinking like because I talked to a
naturopathic doctor about this because I
was thinking surely she would have tried
this you know with her patience and she
was like no I just I I don't think think
that that would work because I think
you'd be you'd have to take it in too
high a Doses and I'm thinking to myself
I want to like let's try that like let's
try it that's weird yeah that's very
strange yeah huh okay it'd be fun if
like anybody who's listening to your
podcast and they're um are like sort of
well-versed in the mechanics of birth
control like in terms of uh how it like
why that would be impossible I'm I'm
just always looking for you know like
why is that impossible because it seems
to be like that's a great idea like why
can't we do it and there's one answer
that's also out there which is that you
know you can't patent
progesterone but you can patent a
progestin ah there we go yeah yeah and
so I think that that might have
something to do with it as
well that's so
infuriating okay this is going this is
going in I had no idea but that makes
total sense that makes more sense I
always thought the birth control like I
said kind of mimicked pregnancy and it
was kind of made from bioidentical
hormones because that's pretty much what
you're
told right yeah yeah and no and it's and
it's not and it essentially it it makes
it it has a hormonal profile that's
similar to the second half of your
menstrual cycle which is when after
you've ovulated and your body is
releasing progesterone and estrogen and
so that daily hormone pill that you take
every day is sort of mimicking that
hormonal message it's relatively high
levels of the synthetic progesterone or
progestin and then low levels of
estrogen and you take that every day and
it makes the brain think that it doesn't
need to stimulate the ovaries to uh
release an egg but like you said I mean
it's it's not progesterone it's a
progestin and so it's stimulating
progesterone receptors but then it's
also doing a bunch of other stuff and um
and a lot of that other stuff is what
makes one women feel bad
lovely I I think also part of the danger
of like putting girls on it when they
haven't experienced Cycles properly like
like say when they're 14 cuz I think I
was I literally think I started taking
it like right after I got my period um I
didn't even know what a cycle felt like
psychologically and so it wasn't until I
was 23 and I stopped taking it and was
like oh I can actually tell what the
first week feels like and the second
week I can feel what ovulation feels
like I know when like I'm more inclined
to work on the second half of my cycle
where I'm I'm just not like I'm not as
interested like I'm going to get down to
business start working whereas the first
half of the Cycles I'm kind of like
floofy and more social and things and it
was fun I was like oh that's what being
females like I was just stuck in this
weird work mode and with who knows how
much extra anxiety for like almost
almost 10 years from the pill that's so
interesting you say that yeah that's so
interesting because I've heard from so
many women that exact same experience
and I had that exact same experience
myself where I felt like I was I mean I
went and I got my PhD and I did all
these things but I was just like yeah
down to business you know just like do
do do and then when I went off of it and
I was like oh this is what it feels like
to feel sexy like yeah
yeah like I didn't realize that I was
missing out on that just all this time
and and you're right I mean it's like
not being able to experience that until
you go off of it it's like what a
shame yeah I got the weirdest thing I
think that happened to me is I started
to be able to and this was kind of gross
too but around when I was ovulating I
started to be able to smell people that
I was walking by so I'd walk by someone
and be like they have a smell I can
smell I haven't smelled that smell
before like what is that and I noticed
it was when when I was ovulating I could
smell people which is I was like that's
really animalistic and basic that I just
didn't have before weird that's that's
so interesting so there was actually a
study done and I talk about this in my
book where they find that very thing
where women right near um what we call
the fertile window so during that period
of time right prior to ovulation um and
and right at ovulation um where you get
increased in sensory sensitivity and
women are like their ability to like
detect the scent of things like
testosterone metabolites for example
increases relative to what's seen
outside that cycle yeah and pilti and
women don't get that they don't have
that experience um and they've also done
some research with the pill looking at
um women's ability to identify
genetically compatible Partners like
based on scent qes and generally what
you find is that um women right near
High fertility that they can um they
exhibit a preference for the scent of
men who are sort of um
immunologically genetically
compatible and what you see is that like
right near high fertility that women you
know experiences preference for the
scent of these genetically compatible
men and for women who are on hormonal
birth control there's nothing there's
like no they never get that increased
preference for genetically compatible
men it's that they have this like
overall like Flatline there's no
preference at all and so this is another
way that taking the pill could
potentially get you in a relationship
with somebody that you don't like and in
fact one of the women I talked to in the
process of writing my book was talking
about scent and she ended up getting a
divorce after um she discontinued the
pill because she didn't like the way
that her husband smelled and it was all
that very thing that you're talking
about um where she just didn't know it's
not that he smelled bad he just didn't
smell
right yeah and that that could sound I'm
sure people will take that the wrong way
like oh how is that a reason to get a
divorce but like if somebody smells good
they smell really good like yeah yeah no
but the idea yeah it's strong and and
the idea that that I mean it's not so
much like oh it's just smell but it was
like but I mean but that really plays an
important role in attraction and and
it's something that I don't think men
understand because there's research that
shows that you know women um sent is
something that we're a lot more
sensitive to and it influences our uh
attraction and partner Choice um to a
much greater extent than it does for men
for men it's it's not even really
something that's very important and
women are a lot more sensitive to it and
it does it it it affects
attraction is there any way for men to
hack that like say they're suffering
from oh also I wanted to talk you said
there's the male birth control pill that
seems to just flatten testosterone which
like nobody is going to want to take
that like no man is going to want to
take that that that was like literally
when I first read the the news story
about like they're creating this pill
that lowers testosterone I'm like
perfect have think have these people met
men like do they know any men like I
don't know a single man who would be
like yes please I'll take one of those
no way a little too motivated feeling a
little too motivated today was take an
anti- testosterone pill yeah no it's
that nuts I just think it's crazy who's
going to take that okay yeah no no no
one and nobody like women wouldn't even
want men to take that that seems like a
terrible idea um no it does is there so
in regards to scent do you know anything
about is there any way for men to hack
this like is it just about raising
testosterone and maybe they'll smell
better or there things they can do
that's a great that's a great question
there was actually a study that came out
just a couple years ago that showed that
um for men who are like who don't like
smell sort of good to women or whatever
um they can actually improve their
attractiveness to Partners just by good
old fashion cologne um and what research
finds is that it's actually really
fascinating is that if you have um men
who are sort of on a range of um you
know masculinity and so you have like
the really masculine guys and you have
guys who are less masculine um and you
have women uh like rating their
attraction to the Man by looking at a
photo and like smelling the man um what
you get is that uh for men who are less
masculine you get this increase in
attraction just based on the presence of
cologne um and it brings those men up to
the same level as the masculine guys but
for masculine guys it does nothing for
them like it doesn't improve their
attractiveness cuz they already smell
attractive to women and so it seems like
the sort of musky scent that tends to
underly um male cologne that you know
it's like chemists have been like
working on trying to make that smell
just right to women for a really long
time seems to be tapping into the to the
right thing and it does seem to um
attract women in the same way um as um
as just good oldfashioned you know cues
of uh testosterone Within the the sweat
glands that's so
sneaky I
know sney which is why it's like um if
you're GNA get together with somebody
like like maybe without cologne like how
about no cologne like I just like let's
spend some time together without cologne
it's like spending time together without
makeup let's
just see what's going on here that's so
funny I was talking to uh graduate
students of mine about test relationship
tests and that was one that the guys
were like yeah you hang out with a girl
with no makeup on and that's that's your
test and now I love it it is a female
equivalent no cologne no deodorant
nothing just I need to smell you and
that should be a test for women I like
that I I completely agree Ah that's
great okay do you think in the future
there's going to be any solutions here
or is what people are playing with
too complicated because of all the
hormones involved and like trying to
stop I feel like trying to stop a body
from getting pregnant which is what
bodies want to do really yes is so
complicated
that is it even like do you see it even
as a possibility that doesn't come with
a host of side effects in the future we
have condoms I mean yeah everyone hates
them but yeah exactly I think that you
know I so I feel hopeful I think it's
going to end up being something totally
outside the box and so just to give you
an example um of something that's
actually being worked on right now and I
don't know whether or not this is going
to end up panning out to anything or not
but there is this um apparently there's
some like vitamin a derivative that our
body it's like some breakdown product of
vitamin A that our bodies use in sperm
production and it seems like it's only
used in sperm production like they're
doing a lot of um research right now and
animal models to make sure that it's
only used and and that the body doesn't
need it for other things um but so far
it seems like really promising and that
that's the only thing it's really used
for and um and it's being used to test
whether if you take something that
blocks that does that prevent sperm
production in men without having any
other side effects um which would be
really fascinating if that's true you
know another thing is like I think it's
going to take outside the box thinking
like I'm I'm just think thinking like
imagine that you have like some sort of
a
little thing that can in your F like a
phian tube where the egg can like fall
out or something like I think it's going
to end up we're going to have to come up
with something that's just totally
different than anything that we've done
before and um so I think that like
outside the box thinking is going to be
really important with this I I also
think that there's a lot you know it's
using uh so for example I use uh natural
Cycles which um uses the aura ring and
so it tracks my basil body temperature
and it's really good at um like telling
me when and and I know also when I'm in
the fertile window I'm just because I'm
pretty in tune with my body but I think
that technology and things that measure
daily body temperature and apps and that
sort of thing that can help isolate the
fertile window for women so that way
they can you know do something else for
birth control or use some form of birth
control just during the periods of time
when they need it over the cycle I think
is also like one of the ways that we're
headed um and so I'm hopeful that um our
ability to successfully predict when
women are in their fertile window gets
better so that way it's more reliable
off for women and they can feel more
confident in that as a birth control
method but um yeah I I feel hopeful that
something's out there but it's going to
have to get away from hormones I mean
there's just no way to not profoundly
affect the entire organism you know with
that when would change a person's
hormonal profile it's just
impossible I feel like that's the right
track because there's only like how many
days a month are women actually fertile
like
five and then if you have so say you
have sex eight days
before the sperms in you long enough you
know there's still a likelihood you can
get pregnant or is it really this 5day
window of having sex that you can get
bra yeah yeah yeah it's about 5 to seven
days in which um yeah that that sex that
you have on that day could potentially
lead to conception and it's the five to
six five to six days prior to ovulation
and then within 24 hours of ovulation um
and so after you it's been 24 hours
since you've ovulated you're home free
and you're generally Home Free about the
first week of your cycle so the first
day of bleeding for about 7 days you're
generally Home Free
but that's not always the case sometimes
a women will have a you know short um
follicular phase and that sort of thing
and which is why it's always a little
tricky to just give a rule of thumb like
that because you could give a rule of
thumb and then somebody ends up pregnant
so um but as a general rule of thumb not
to be used as birth control um that
first seven days of your cycle are
usually reasonably safe after you know
you've ovulated if it's been 24 hours
you're generally safe for about almost 2
weeks
so okay so I've got I have a couple of
questions one when you're taking this
say you're taking the birth control pill
that stops your cycle for like 3 months
or it does something for 3 months and
then it says there's like a bunch of
sugar pills you take those for a week
and you bleed is it actually uterine
lining given the fact you haven't
ovulated like what's going on there yeah
no it's not uterine lining cuz you're
not it it's just blood it's just
essentially when you have a hormone
crash in your body that um sends a
signal to your um to your endometrial
layer to to start to um shed and and and
release blood flow and so that's really
all that that is there's a little bit of
uteral lining cuz like there's a tiny
bit of estrogen and especially in these
combination pills and estrogen is
proliferative and causes the cells in
the um uterine lining to proliferate so
there's a little bit of it but not much
so the the period that you have on the
pill isn't really a period it's um it's
just a withdrawal
bleed H
okay that's yeah okay and then the other
question that's also why like oh I was
just to say that that's that's another
reason why um you know for a lot of
women who have been on the pill for a
while and then they go off of it they're
they find that their periods are a lot
more
gnarly than they were you know before um
when they were on the pill like CU those
you know the period that you have when
you're on the pills it tends to be very
light cuz there's not a lot of
endometrial
material and then like once you actually
start
sheding it can be a little bit like um
like whoo uh surprising to women just
because it's a little bit of a different
Beast than so that's why it that's why
it improves your
period yeah because you're not
proliferating your uh uterine lining
isn't proliferating and so you're not
having as much there's not all those
contractions and everything else you
don't have as many cramps there's not as
much material with your with your period
as you get when you're naturally cycling
which um sometimes with some women can
be you know have clots it and other
things which is totally normal when you
are shutting an endometrial
any huh okay and then that makes that
makes more sense and then is it possible
to ovulate twice in a month does that
ever happen no I mean it can if you have
two eggs at one time like sometimes two
eggs will get released and then you end
up with fraternal twins um okay you know
and if both of them implanted but that
is very it's pretty rare um but you
won't ever get a case where you will
ovulate um and then uh and then ovulate
like a week later and then end up with
like a sequential pregnancy okay so that
can happen so then mostly the variation
is just ovulating early or late if it
changes right exactly and generally like
the follicular phase which is the first
half of the cycle when um the egg
follicles are maturing and estrogen is
being released and all that sort of
thing everything prior to ovulation that
part of the cycle tends to be more
variable in length so sometimes it can
be longer shorter the ludal of the cycle
um is generally about 2 weeks and it's
it's a lot less variable it's it's
pretty it's pretty um stable unless you
have um failure to ovulate which does
happen especially in women like Western
women all of us who are stressed out all
the time um you can get ovulatory
disturbances fairly frequently
that makes sense um did you I mean you
you probably know of this study uh it
was a study on how women dress when
they're
ovulating yeah can you describe that a
bit sure so um when women are ovulating
they tend to show more skin uh they tend
to wear sexier and more revealing
clothing and research even finds that
they're more likely to wear the color
red relative to what you see outside the
fertile window um and this is just
because women feel sexy at that time
they have an increase in sexual
motivation and they also like feel
sexier and they tend to feel better
about themselves and um and they show it
um by going out and wearing less and um
yeah dressing
sexier that's cool it is really cool did
you there's something else I read I
don't remember where I read this but um
for for men supplementing testosterone
can do like wonders right if you have
low testosterone it can take away your
motivation like you said and your energy
and your libido and it can be awful um
I've read some stories of women
accidentally getting testosterone cream
or anything on themselves when they
didn't need it and experiencing wild
heightened sexual arousal have you do
you know anything about that is that
true I haven't heard of that but that
would be absolutely consistent with t
testosterone so testosterone um it's a
powerful sexual motivator in men but it
also plays a role in women's sexual
desire so for women sexual desire is
really a function of like well I mean
there a lot of things it's relationship
quality and all these other things but
in terms of the hormonal drivers um it's
estrad or estrogen and then testosterone
and those two things together um promote
women's sexual desire and in fact one of
the uh therapies that especially women
as they're going through the menopausal
transition are given to help revive
their libido is is
testosterone that's cool yeah no totally
totally our hormones are
awesome okay well when women are going
through like menopause and trying to
figure that out uh is the supplement
usually oral or can it be injected do
the creams work do you know anything
about that like do these creams work
yeah so the creams work like um the
because they actually test whether or
not women's hormones are changing in
response to the treatments that they're
given and so yeah there's a lot of
research validating the the use of the
creams in terms of raising women's like
estrad levels for example so generally
the cream is um is estrogen um but you
can also get estrogen in a patch and
that's usually the way that estrogen is
is administered is with the is with a
patch or with um a cream and then
progesterone is a pill um and then
testosterone it can be you can get an
injection there are pellets it can get
put subdermally they get under your skin
and then it releases a certain amount of
testosterone every day um and uh and
these are all sort of the the usual
therapies that are included in
menopausal hormone
therapy cool okay well Sarah I think
that answered my question that taught me
a bunch too I didn't realize progestin I
I know it's called progestin it's not
called progesterone I didn't realize
that that was a totally synthetic
hormone that actively works on other
hormones as opposed to just pure
progesterone that is concerning so
that's very good to know and the fact
that just taking natural hormones like
say for postmenopausal women isn't the
same as taking birth control that's good
to know too yeah right yeah yeah and
just make sure that it is because some
doctors do treat women in transition
with birth control pills um and so when
you if you're a woman who's going
through the menopausal transition and
you want to talk to your doctor about
hormone therapy just make sure that
you're using the body identical um
progesterone and um in estrogen and
that's what most doctors use but there
are still some who prescribe birth
control pills okay well thank you that
was really interesting thanks very much
yeah of course so that was
fun
[Music]
n